hello welcome Happy release day
[Applause]
I don't think I've ever
this has been the longest it's been
since I've released new music that's not
Christmas
I feel like somebody said it was like
six years and I think that's not that
can't be true but it might be we have
the Christmas album I mean like new like
knots
maybe okay it's been a minute
um
um but so there's a lot in it
um yeah but I I am so excited um I've
already heard I've been working all day
but I've been hearing from people
um because this is my by the way this is
my office so you're my desk right now at
the Kelly Clarkson show what having some
tea
um and um I'm actually about to
interview somebody I love and adore so
I'm very excited but right now we are
here to talk about my stuff so
um anyway I am very excited we released
mine and me we couldn't decide and
honestly those weren't even the first
ones up for to be releasing single we
had like different ideas and I will say
this is the first project I was just
like
I'm really cool with any song being
released like whichever one so I I kind
of let Atlantic pick
um I love my team at Atlantic
um you have no idea how much I love them
to finish up this record shout out
Carrie and Craig
um it just it was a very personal record
and it had a
most of the vocals were like you know
recorded a while back so anyway it was
just a very intense record for me to not
only make and
and do but also just very therapeutic
and and like also like will I release
this I don't know and
um anyway I did so we are doing it and I
now can say
that the album is coming out okay I can
play Trisha wait 23rd I was like look
I'm confused on the date so I'm like or
when we're I'm allowed to say certain
things and I'm also not allowed to say
this one thing that literally is on the
tip of my tongue that I normally talk
about so we're not gonna talk about it
anyway but it's like the one thing
because I'm ADHD
but June 23rd the album is coming out uh
the singles just came out today I've
never released two at once
um I did that uh actually the the label
asked me if I was cool then I've always
had that idea to release more than one
song for albums because I feel like it's
hard to like encapsulate like what
exactly a whole album is with one song
you can't do that right so anyway we did
um mine and me which are very different
versions of
or I guess I should rather say stages of
grief um in that but um but the whole
album isn't just grief and loss it's
it's a whole Arc of a relationship so I
just hit my hand on my lovely cup what
Kelly Clarkson's job
um and anyway it said why did you
release two songs on the same day
everybody has been asking me that
um we just kind of both everybody had
the same idea and kind of you know
Atlantic said it and we were like wow we
were thinking the same thing so
um we were stoked about doing that I I
love that they're so different like I
don't think I've ever recorded anything
like mine in my life so and I I've never
written how I wrote that song like it
was it's very different how that came
out and I love I think the closest song
might be maybe which is another song I
did like it was just kind of extreme of
Consciousness but um but me
um I'm super excited about me because
here's the thing I've never met Gail I'm
just a huge fan and I didn't actually
know that we were on the same label
whenever I was raving about this girl
that had just come out this is years ago
I was like the scotch came out I was
like she got this Killer song and I was
like I don't know how nobody has thought
of this yet anyway and my label
proceeded to tell me like yeah we're
really into her too because she's you
know our artist and I was like cool
um anyway I didn't know anyway so they
know I'm a fan of hers and
they knew I had written so many songs I
was just working so much and it was very
personal it was very hard like songs
that were coming in from other writers
weren't necessarily it wasn't that they
weren't great songs it just wasn't
what this called for this project if I
was gonna do it I just felt like I
really had to do it do it honestly and
and you know just be a little bit more
raw and like very personal so I was
having a hard time with other writers
but then I got this um idea via I can't
refer as Carrie Craig at Atlantic one of
them actually sent me this idea and uh I
believe it was Carrie but anyway she it
was a verse in a chorus from Gail and it
was me it was the idea for me
and I was so thankful I mean I'm so
people are loving this song I'm very
happy for that obviously but for me
selfishly I was having a really hard
time
I I hadn't written that song for the
album yet I hadn't written anything like
that because I had I wasn't really
feeling that at the moment so
um it was a really cool thing I was very
thankful for Gail's existence
um just for me personally just to be
able to finish right I literally got the
song the idea and then I finished it
that night like I was like I ended up
writing the second verse and um bridge
that night like to that I was like oh my
gosh I love I love this song it's so
it's exactly what I needed to kind of
round out
um what had kind of already been going
on in the album so shout out to Gail we
could not be more different in age but
that just goes to show you how powerful
music is man it doesn't matter what your
age is we all go through scenarios and
situations and I have no idea honestly
to this date like what she wrote that
first part about for her
um but mine definitely you know comes in
in that that second verse and and it is
my story so it was interesting
collaborate to collaborate and that's it
I've never done it like that before
um
mine though I will say mine is exciting
for me because
it just feels like this
it was hard for me to describe to people
what I was going through and I was
writing it and
it was it's so you know like the verses
sound kind of like this sad really sad
secret you know and it's very quiet and
and then it explodes into this not even
lead vocal it's funny because like the
bgvs that I recorded that's like all me
on there but like it's like those gang
vocals
that's how I was feeling emotionally
like and I needed it I was like I want
to do a ton of you know voice I want to
sound like I haven't really sounded
before
um and my nod to Green Day I'm a huge
Green Day fan so I mean it feels like
just kind of that big huge chorus with
that straight tone singing and
um and it's what I needed like to to get
that out so um
I don't know and then I've never written
a song like this I wrote that song and
then left it didn't have a bridge yet
because I just wasn't feeling it and I
was like I gotta go and I need to get
out of these emotions out of my house
poor Jessie shotkin at my house we're
doing like 25 songs in two days anyway
but I ended up riding the bridge later
and I thought he was gonna think I was
nuts because I wanted to change the
tempo
um I was like I know this sounds crazy
but I really feel like the tempo should
pick up here because emotionally that's
where I'm at and I just got frustrated
it was I was frustrated I was very angry
and um and like I said I wrote most two
songs like two and a half to three years
ago so while it is me it's just I'm in a
very different place now so it's really
love being on the other side you can't
express that enough you know when people
are like there's the end of the tunnel
you just can't see it I'm like you're
lying
it's not there it's all just
everything's gonna die like it's just
everything's bad and um you just don't
see it do ya um but it happened what was
the time difference between so I changed
the time in the song My like it changes
Tempo oh right good as I rush I wanted
it to rush a bit more and I want it to
feel a little bit more like
just frustrated it wasn't even angry
just frustrated is what I was feeling so
um yeah but it's kind of like that thing
where
you know it doesn't even matter what
side of the relationship around too I
think anybody that's been in any
relationship maybe you've felt that
before like
where you feel like you were connecting
and you didn't and it and it just was
it just feels like the rug was you know
the rug was kind of
yeah stolen from beneath you so yeah
that was a very very sad time really
glad once again I'm not there so
and between mine and may how long was
that between writing both those songs
um maybe just like a couple months I
mean I literally have had these songs
for years so like
um yeah maybe just months in between and
I think it was really clever of Carrie
who I work with at Atlantic because
I was having a hard time connecting to
even though I love songs that are being
sent it just wasn't where I was and for
this chapter
um of my life and it was very hard it's
like how can someone possibly know what
I'm feeling right so
um that's how I felt but anyway turns
out Gail did
um and also Rachel actually there's
there's
that's one song I wrote with and then
all the other ones except for there's
there's two on there that um are by
other writers that I I just connected
with and I felt like we're very much
part of this story so yeah yeah are you
performing uh mine maybe live at some
point am I am I performing live maybe
I'm the first live performance of mine
we um it's happening this uh Tuesday
April 14th on my show and it was so
interesting because if you'll if you
listen to the song you know there's a
lot you can do in a studio it's a very
dramatic vocal like it's very intense
like Bob who does my in-ears was like oh
my gosh
because I'm very quiet I was like oh Bob
you got to turn we can't hear me in the
verse and then I just whale in the
chorus and then you know I'm very
frustrated in the the bridge and then it
comes right back down so poor Bob was
just riding that vocal the entire time
um in my in-ears so I'd actually pop one
out so I could hear the room
um but anyway it's it's a very intense
song and and um that'll be the first
performance is on the Kelly Clarkson
show what yeah they have some tea with
that thought so Kelly a lot of your fans
talk about how many of your songs and
their lyrics help them through tough
times so when you were writing these new
songs which lyrics do you feel really
helped you the most when you were
writing them in a cathartic way
question so really all of them in a
different way like even like there's a
it's it's funny because it's gonna sound
weird but even there's a song called
favorite kind of high which is like more
of an upbeat like
Anthem and like more of like that
intoxicating part of relationship right
so
um even with that song it was good for
me and I said this from the very
beginning with labo it's very good for
me to be able
to experience the whole relationship on
this album because to diminish something
to just bad
would be a disservice so it's not all
bad right and all really it's not even
that
anyone's bad it just doesn't work
sometimes and things don't align or
whatnot so
um or I don't know what beer deal is
maybe it didn't go well in a different
way but anyway mine particularly was
important for me to have
songs like that to remember that it
wasn't all it was very helpful to pull
myself out of the gutter
that I was living in
um because you know your whole world
changes and you're like I didn't see
that coming
um and anyway so it's it's very
important to remember the good as well
and not just sit in the crappy you know
so um it's all there so all of them are
important and all of them have that but
I love those records and honestly that's
why I released this record I was very
worried about it because I didn't know
if I'd want to talk about it all the
time because I don't enjoy that
um but I think that it's very important
to still be the same artist I've been my
whole career which is very open and
honest and and also
like several songs didn't make the cut
because they were maybe too honest so
um so I filtered myself and I put out
the songs these 14 songs I feel like are
relatable for anyone like it's not so
pointed just at like me and what I'm
going through I like all your heart
somebody just give me a bunch of Hearts
yeah yeah which song on the album do you
feel like is most personal that you were
kind of on the fence about
um I think just well there's two
different answers for me so
um I was on the fence about red flag
collector
laughs
for many reasons but
um but I had so many people you know
talk about
how that you know we've make these jokes
like oh just collecting red flags
um you know would just make these drugs
I thought it's kind of relatable so I
kept it anyway but the most personal
for me
which I think a lot of people experience
in a relationship is
you're on the fence of what to do right
you're just you don't know like should I
keep doing this should I keep going or
should you save yourself you just don't
know and that's chemistry that's the
song chemistry for me so
um and I've never recorded anything like
that song either it's very different
kind of a nod to to Buckley I'm a fan of
Jeff Buckley so it's kind of a little
bit of a nod to that
um anyway yeah
um okay so uh reaction to me what is the
reason what a fans saying oh are you I
look like an old person I just leaned in
I said are there any country songs on
the album I can say other or some of the
genres that you've got on the album
um
we reference country but it's it's not
it's not this is not like one day I will
make a full-on exactly how I wanted to
sound country I'm because I love country
music
um and it'll be exactly like what I
wanted this is not that if you're
looking for that album that's not this
album this album is very much I mean
it's very much pop but it's got some
singer-songwriter stuff on there it's
got some punk rock it's got some uh
soulfulness on there it's it's kind of a
marriage I feel like of like
Breakaway stronger and meaning of life
like there's just elements of all of
that in there
um so but yeah it's not a this is not a
country record I mean if you heard the
two singles and thought that this might
be a country record
you maybe don't know country music it's
like it's like this is not because I
love all kinds of music and and
sometimes a lot of times when I write
um
which actually I did write some country
during this
um that might come out one day but um
but that for as a whole it came out like
therapeutically more pop rock kind of
Soulful fans are already comparing it to
my December do you feel like you bring
those kind of just memories and
Inspirations through oh so my December
you know what it is
it's different sonically from my
December but it's very similar in the
sense that it's just very raw and very
me
um yes I would say that is a similarity
um but I will say the giant difference
between that record and this record is I
had never
been in love like I'd never thought oh
I'm gonna end up on a porch with this
dude like and we're gonna rock away the
life together and I didn't ever know
that and I think that there's a big
difference in the person that recorded
my December
and the person that recorded this record
there's just you know I'm 40 so
hopefully I've lived a little to
to you know know a little bit more
um and just experiences right I think
that changes us as well
when it comes to May and you basically
took us to church yeah uh so what was
the inspiration for making that so big
and anthemic
um it just kind of came out especially
like I said earlier like when Gail like
with what she had written I was like
okay I was like I don't know what she's
talking about but like what her thing is
and why she went here but like for me I
obviously personalized it for me and it
and it ended up being
um
I love a fluck I love a big bold Soulful
ballad Anthem like right I'm into that
so that worked but also it's just how it
came out it's just how
I know this sounds weird but certain
like emotions and certain like feelings
come out better with different genres of
music for me
and that sounds like I have different
people in here I don't that's just me
but um but it's it just it came out more
Soulful because of how I need it
especially like certain things that I'd
been wanting to say in songs and get out
and write and hadn't been able to like
like honestly like one of my favorite
lines in on the whole record is too weak
to stand next to me and that's not I
know it sounds like a big dig and it is
a bit of a dig but it's more or less the
line of like we're not at the same place
right now and that's okay but like I
need this
and and and I need to find this is what
I need you know so it was kind of cool
everybody's doing what are we doing or
is are we late oh okay I was like are we
in my I have to tape a show after this I
was like are we going I was everybody
was looking anyway so it's it's more
I know it can seem like a lot like digs
on certain things but it was more of
like that is the word that that is what
I meant like you know like in a sense of
like we're just you know sometimes at
different places and it doesn't match up
and it and it's it could relationship
can be hard but they can be too hard you
know so anyway well they've got a lot of
amazing comments here Kelly some of your
fans are reaching out I'm so first of
all if you're saying I relate I'm sorry
like there is nothing worse than
somebody coming up to me and saying
gotta relate to this song and it's
usually the saddest song in my catalog
and I'm like oh my God I'm sorry but I
also get the connection so I'm grateful
for that um that's the whole point but
um what collabs are on it I just saw
that question so I don't know how I had
I don't know how this happened but I got
Sheila Ian Steve Martin to agree to be
on my album
what that's right I was so excited
you're gonna there's a reason
a big reason why Steve Martin white
asked him
um on I hate love to be a part of it but
anyway he's an amazing musician I love
him obviously he's Steve Martin we all
do
um as an actor but there was something
in particular that kind of stood out for
me and I mentioned in a song anyway he
was part of it was very cool and I love
Sheila E she's played with us on the
show I've played with her on award shows
I just love her not only as a talented
musician she's just legit a genuinely
kind great human and that is who I want
to work with and I want to celebrate
music with so she's on that's right
which is so sassy
oh they're saying okay sorry
um
wait let me see before me
oh oh I can't answer that question
someone almost got me in trouble I
almost said something I tried it yeah
I know I know I was like I know I was
like I'm so sorry uh so I'm just trying
to filter myself a little bit because we
do have a surprise coming soon uh will
the new album be out on vinyl you bet
your ass I love vinyl that's how I love
listening to music y'all it's so good
um different colors too I know I picked
I picked so many different different
covers for it different colors for the
bottom yeah it's gonna be really cool oh
my gosh and Brian bone Smith just shout
out he is like incredible we did this
incredible photo shoot for that look at
this
look at that it's not photoshopped like
everybody that was the thing I was like
you just did that and it's not it was
because I kept telling him like I almost
called chemistry there's a lot of
different feelings kind of jumping out
of me it's like all these everything in
hand this whole idea because he's
brilliant and I love him and um and even
on the back I love that I love it it's
beautiful I love it he did such a great
job so yes there will be vinyl
um and let me see oh Eternal Sunshine of
the Spotless Mind yes I got that line
because that movie
um
yeah unfortunately yeah it doesn't exist
I asked it's like it just you can't get
that erase so
um but you don't want to because you
wanna remember the good times too but
anyway I learned that in therapy but how
do you feel today is release time I feel
I feel so good I love you yeah I love
Andy so much
um I I feel really good I literally was
texting Trisha last night I was like I'm
so excited the songs are out like two of
the songs are out but I'm really excited
I know but she knows what I'm gonna say
I was like I wish
because I just really want the whole
thing to be heard
not just one or two songs because it's
so important because it's not like I
said I just don't want it to be down to
one feeling because that's not that's
just such a disservice to a a whole you
know relationship so anyway I'm very
excited yeah that does come out June
23rd it's coming out and I can say it
now
um it without getting in trouble
um so I do have a on Monday I have a
special announcement that I almost
written here
didn't do it though I I'm such a
professional
um but Monday yeah we have something so
exciting that literally
I've wanted to do for from the beginning
of the process of this album I've wanted
to do so I'm very excited about it
um anyway and April's such a fun month
because it's my birthday this month what
anyway
um and my son just turned seven because
he's awesome
um happy birthday Remy shut up
um okay I gotta go shoot another show
I'm very excited
um about my interview that I'm about to
do so anyway uh bye thank you guys so
much for tuning in I hope you like the
songs if you don't I'm like sorry
they're already done so that's it like
it's like I'm sorry but um on Monday
um but thank you for supporting them
thank you for for getting the music
thank you for supporting I it really
does mean a lot um more so that y'all
connect to it right so um that's the
whole point
um of what art is so anyway
um I hope you're having an awesome day
uh check back in with us Monday because
we got a really fun announcement anyway
[Laughter]
um you sexy Australian Beast oh good day
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]